so straight with this consent we talked
about this little yesterday in our
section on sort of putting the community
goals or whatever goals ahead of your
own personal goal if you're sort of a if
you're an economist or game theorists
you could certainly explain it as some
of the actually putting their own
personal goals but but fitting them to a
longer time frame so there no my comment
really is but it seems like there is a
another appropriate economic explanation
that goes beyond religious conviction or
values based convictions in that in that
case the curious what your thoughts
right so so so that we may each of us
may have some stake in being a
longer-term altruist because your
interest is bound up with the
community's interest and therefore
whatever you do for the community you
it's not some kind of a irrational
generosity on your part but rather it is
very rationally thought through
conception of how the whole fits
together at your place in it then your
good is bound up with the good of others
and therefore you ought to promote it
right you know there we can yes please I
guess a question
looking at leaders in the market who do
not who are novel is and how they can
sort of develop the similar moral base
that their colleagues or other marketers
who are religious so that they can work
together to achieve similar goals
whether or not we are it says that's
that's going in Jose Jose directions so
that the kind of concern for the common
good may not necessarily need not
necessarily come from religious
traditions or need not be based deeply
on some altruistic motives but rather
could come could come from other sources
but that in fact you may have been
overlapping convictions and would be
able possibly to work some of us
justifying it in one way others of us
just EP justifying it in different way
but nonetheless you would have at least
significantly overlapping conceptions of
something like a common global common
good there was